Атмосфера - майже як в армії. Команди, однострій, чіткі правила.
Так звичайні цивільні люди навчаються одній з найнебезпечніших професій - роботі демінера.
26-річна Юлія раніше працювала фінансистом.
У рідному селі Богданівка під Броварами разом з батьками пережила російську окупацію.
Після цього звільнилася з роботи, аби піти навчатися на демінера.
Я пішла на співбесіду, нікому вдома нічого не сказала. Мені сказали - чекайте дзвінка.
Я дочекалася дзвінка, звільнилася з роботи зі своєї і потім уже вдома сказала.
Тому батьки ще досі перебувають у шоковому стані.
Юлія - одна з 15 дівчат серед 90 людей у групі.
З важким металодетектором у руках дівчина ретельно перевіряє кожен квадратний метр своєї робочої ділянки
- поки без справжніх мін.
Ось ми знайшли сигнал, нам треба його відмітити, щоб ми його не пропустили.
Бо після нас не залишається жодного сигналу, не може залишатися.
Цей курс міжнародна гуманітарна організація HALO Trust пропонує усім, хто хоче стати демінером.
Спершу - безкоштовно навчають, потім - працевлаштовують.
В'ячеслав з Херсона відпрацьовує найскладніший метод розмінування - повну екскавацію.
Так шукають протипіхотні міни.
Вони можуть перебувати на глибині до семи сантиметрів, а то й глибше.
Заглиблюємося на 2-3 сантиметри вперед. Знизу вгору.
Це може цілий день тривати, і два дні, і три дні.
Кропітка робота не лякає В'ячеслава. Для нього найстрашніше - позаду.
Разом із дружиною і двома доньками він провів два місяці в окупованому Херсоні.
До війни чоловік працював на "Новій пошті" електромеханіком.
За словами В'ячеслава, відділення пошти росіяни пограбували у перші ж дні окупації.
Спочатку більш-менш було в місті тихо. А потім почався терор.
Ми виходили на мітинги, потім стали стріляти в людей на мітингах…
Чоловік з родиною виїхав до родичів на Київщину.
Тут випадково дізнався про вакансію демінера. Пройшов співбесіду і потрапив на навчання.
Мені запропонували інші посади на співбесіді.
Ну а я кажу - та ні, мені хочеться демінером.
З самого початку така думка була, щоб рідні території уже після деокупації, після війни
мати можливість розмінувати, допомагати. Тому що я знаю кожен метр рідного краю, Херсонщини,
і там мої діти будуть жити, переміщатися, і це дуже важливо.
З 2015 року HALO Trust працювала на Донбасі. Організація розмінувала 420 гектарів земель.
Працювали над цим так само цивільні українці, які навчилися демінуванню "з нуля".
HALO стала роботодавцем для понад 400 місцевих.
Серед них і Марина, у минулому - економіст, а нині - інструкторка, яка передає свій досвід іншим.
Головне - стан здоров'я. Якщо у людини є проблеми з колінами,
вона - алергік, який не переносить укуси бджіл, бо ж ми працюємо на природі, де все на свіжому повітрі,
якщо вона - астматик чи є проблеми з серцем чи тиском, зрозуміло,
що цим людям буде набагато складніше працювати.
24 лютого Марина з дітьми виїхала з рідного Краматорська, а її чоловік пішов на фронт.
Нині жінка мріє повернутися додому. Хоча після трьох років розмінування,
її батьківщина тепер знову забруднена мінами.
Нам образливо, що ми розмінували Донецьку і Луганську області і зараз це доведеться заново робити.
Коли поля, які ти проходив своїми колінами і руками, тобі доведеться їх заново розміновувати.
Але ми не розчаровуємося, для нас головне, щоб наша Україна перемогла і ми повернулися додому.
Марина розповідає, що за час її роботи в HALO жоден демінер не загинув і не травмувався.
Усе завдяки суворим стандартам і протоколам.
Наприклад, ось так, повільно й виважено, студент Сергій перевіряє наявність розтяжок.
Ось такими рухами… Від землі до рівня очей.
Демінери - не сапери. Вони не беруть до рук боєприпаси й міни, не знешкоджують їх.
Лише знаходять небезпечний предмет, відмічають, і викликають саперів ДСНС.
Сергій, батько трьох дітей, свою майбутню професію вважає безпечною, хоча зізнається - дружина хвилюється.
Але я знаю з досвіду, що стандарти HALO Trust дуже високі в плані безпеки.
Ну і засоби захисту, обладнання тут найновіші, і якщо дотримуватися процедур безпеки,
то, скажімо так, на 99 відсотків це безпечна робота.
Сергій родом з Кривого Рогу. За фахом він геодезист.
Працював із підприємством, яке через війну зупинилося, тож чоловік переїхав до столиці
і на сайті з пошуку роботи знайшов вакансію демінера.
По-перше, це робота на свіжому повітрі постійно.
Не в кабінеті за комп'ютером, де в тебе постійно очі вже не бачать екрана, а тобі треба робити.
Немає абсолютно ніякого психологічного тиску стосовно плану роботи, стосовно норми.
Нормування немає, працюєш спокійно.
Зарплата демінера стартує від 24 тисяч гривень, за відрядження є надбавки.
Крім того можна "зростати" до керівника групи, інструктора.
Робота триває у дощ і спеку, але припиняється під час зимових морозів.
Поки до них далеко, майбутні демінери, зокрема і Юлія, готуються до фінального іспиту.
До нього дійшли не всі студенти: з понад ста людей у групі на початку залишилися 90.
Юлія розповідає: декому робота стала не до душі, але не їй.
Я знала, що я буду триматися. В принципі холоду, спеки, роботи я не боюся, тому мені не так важко,
як здається моїм батькам.
Вчитися наполегливо дівчину мотивують стіни власного будинку -
нещодавно відбудовані після "прильоту", але все ще посічені уламками.
Юлія говорить, що хоче якнайшвидше очистити свою землю від нагадувань про окупацію.
Краще їх просто прибрати і забути. Ніж сидіти і думати, що вони десь є, а ти не знаєш, що з ними робити.
Для цього ми і навчаємося, щоб знати, що робити, щоб могти їх ідентифікувати
і хоча б повідомити правильно, куди треба.
Група, з якою навчається Юлія, - вже четвертий випуск демінерів на Київщині.
Пройшли навчання й стали до роботи близько трьохсот людей.
Утім, в масштабах України, цього замало, кажуть демінери.
Адже за світовою статистикою, один день активної війни - це місяць ретельного розмінування,
для якого потрібні сотні робочих рук.